6
25 on your wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy how about piling on
for already beleaguered drivers around
that las vegas boulevard repaving
project that
many folks call a nightmare so in
addition to the bumpy confusing
frustrating stop-and-go ride along the
strip hey guess what
now there's word of sewer work taking up
lanes on elvis presley boulevard
and paradise around the convention
center so for elvis presley that work is
going to be
mainly in the center lane any time of
day
until june the 20th for paradise you're
losing the two right lanes southbound
from elvis presley down to convention
center that's from nine each night until
five
each following morning now for those of
you wondering if the work on las vegas
boulevard is going to be done
by the time of resorts world's announced
opening day to june 24th
well we're wondering too stay tuned
we'll for sure keep you posted about
that
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone if there's something
driving you crazy email me
traffic 8 8newsnow.com